Microsoft is apparently discontinuing
their clip art the clip art that comes
when you get windows it comes for free
they're discontinuing it they're getting
rid of it ladies and gentlemen I happen
to be an art collector I love that that
gets giggles and I bought I bought the
entire collection of Microsoft's clip
art yeah and I was wondering do you want
to see some of the masterpieces these
are these are all actual real clip art
images we did not create these this is
sentence no wonder they discontinued
them this one I call at our school bus
company your child safety is our fifth
priority I don't see one seat belt no
this one I call even bonds love bonds I
call this one you are approaching a
minimum security prison
I call this one you are invited to the
wedding of gay dice okay you won't be
seeing that tonight what was the one
before it Andy minimum security prison
yes minimum security prison I call this
one hey can you help me move a body I
call this one see I told you Annie was
black now I call this one honey the
amazing acid bath really works Wow and
finally I call this one uncle Ted
finally looks happy
you
you